not just regular permutations super
permutations can leap tall buildings in
a single bound permutations what is a
super permutation first of all let's
talk about an ordinary permutation a
permutation is just like a shuffle so
imagine I had three cards one two and
three how many ways can I shuffle those
three cards so let's do that these are
the permutations
1 2 3 and we could have 1 3 2 2 1 3 2 3
1 and we could have 3 1 2 & 3 2 1
there are six permutations that use the
numbers 1 2 3 and that is 3 factorial
just to remind people 3 factorial means
3 times 2 times 1 and that's because
we've got three choices for the first
one two choices for the second one and
one choice for the last one and you
multiply those choices together that's 3
factorial that's 6 there are 6 ways to
do it there are super permutation it's a
string of numbers that contains all the
permutations so the super permutation of
1 2 & 3 would have all the permutations
of 1 2 & 3 contained within it so we
could just string these together now
that's simple right
1 2 3 1 3 2 2 1 3 2 3 1 3 1 2 3 2 1 so
that's a super permutation it has length
18 you don't seem that impressed with
that super permutation it doesn't
deserve its name as being super ok we
can do better what is the smallest
string of numbers that we can write that
contains all of permutations well how
about this one 1 2 3 1 2 1 3 2 1 all
right this has length 9 but it is a
super permutation and it's the shortest
super permutation using 1 2 3 this check
so it has a have used overlaps this best
check 1 2 3 that's in there 1 3 2 I've
got it here 2 1 3
where is it there it is 2 3 1 right
there near the beginning 3 1 2 I bet
that is here and 3
- one is right at the end yes it
contains all the permutations but it is
the shortest string that contains all
the permutations and it has length 9 so
let's have a look at the shortest super
permutations for all the values 1 2 3 1
2 4 let's have a look so they start with
1 ok the super permutation containing
all the permutations of 1 is 1 and then
we just check yes that contains all the
permutations it has length 1
great well what is the super permutation
for 1 & 2 it is 1 to 1 so it has 1 & 2
and it has 2 & 1 that's all you need and
that has length 3 as you can see now for
3 we've done that one and we have a
super permutation of length 9 now for
I'm gonna take 4 has length 33 so let's
have a look at what that looks like 1 2
3 4 2 1 3 2 1 4 3 2 1
there we go so that has length 33 and it
contains all the permutations so 5 what
is the super permutation 5 it has length
153 so I'm like that one out
it is escalating and then for 6 don't
know no we don't know what is the super
permutation or the minimum super
permutation using 1 6 we have a guess ok
so there is a pattern of maybe this
guess is right have a look this first
number it was 1 and that is 1 factorial
the second number is 3 actually that
turns out to be 1 factorial plus 2
factorial 9 1 factorial plus 2 factorial
plus 3 factorial you might notice a
pattern for 33
well that is 1 factorial plus 2
factorial plus 3 factorial plus 4
factorial what do you what do you guess
5 is going to be yeah 1 factorial plus 2
factorial plus 3 factorial
plus four factorial plus five factorial
is 153 so six what do you guess stick is
going to be adding up the factorials
let's do it 1 factorial + 2 factorial
plus 3 factorial + 4 factorial plus 5
factorial + 6 factorial 873 I think
that's a pretty good guess for the
minimum length of the super permutation
using 1 - 6
unfortunately recently someone found a
super permutation that is shorter in
fact they found a super permutation that
had length 872 1 shorter the pattern did
not hold it was 1 shorter so and I can
show you what that looks like this is it
on the screen and we still don't know if
that's the shortest one we still don't
know if the answer is 872 it's possible
there is a shorter one out there it was
a little bit of a shock well you can see
this pattern and there's a reason why
you would think this pattern would hold
there is a way to construct the next
super permutation from the previous one
and if you construct it in that way then
absolutely the super permutation will
have that length and so they were just
thinking well that must be the minimum
length this shows they were wrong it
isn't the minimum length it is not
necessary for it to be the minimum thing
now you can see that this might become
harder the large of these numbers
becomes it's it's actually
computationally hard so maybe we'll find
what the minimum length is 4 6 and then
we'll have to work out 7 and so on and
this is going to get harder and harder
unless we find some clever construction
of the minimum super permutations that
tells us what the minimum length is this
is worth comparing to something called
two Brown sequences and the brown
sequences are a similar idea
but they contain all the sequences using
let's say one two three you would
contain all the sequences it would look
like this so here's a the brown sequence
similar idea 1 1 1 2 1 1 3 1 2 2 1 2 3 1
3 2 1 3 3 2 2 2 3 2 3 3 3 1 1 so here we
have a sequence and it contains all
sequences of length 3 using numbers 1 2
3 so 1 1 1 is in there 1 1 2 is in there
3 3 3 is in there 3 1 3 is in there so
the brown sequences are a lot like super
permutations but the sequences inside
are allowed to contain duplicates but we
have a way to construct the brown
sequences and it constructs the minimum
length the brown sequence as well and
they have practical applications in
robotics and in actually lots of other
areas where DNA sequencing and all lots
of unexpected applications so the brown
sequences although I think should be
harder really but where they're
completely understood but super
permutations they're still a little bit
mysterious the great courses plus is an
on-demand video service with lessons and
courses taught by leading professors
from universities and institutions all
around the world they've got an
extensive library of 8,000 videos
covering pretty much anything that might
take your fancy from playing chess to
the geography of Antarctica I'm actually
heading to Antarctica myself in the next
few weeks so I've been paying
particularly close attention to those
lessons it's about 50% larger than the
United States including Alaska they're
really good really in-depth stuff if all
of this ice melted the global sea level
would rise about 60 meters that's 200
feet but whatever you're into you're
gonna find something really good here
learn at your own pace no homework no
teachers telling you off but new stuff
being added to the site every month for
a free trial and the great courses plus
and to show some support for numberphile
go visit the great courses
plus.com / numberphile that's the
address there the great course is
plus.com / numberphile our thanks to
them for supporting this episode
[Music]